palmer
can you do topless waitering with the
guests yeah yeah get an eye patch or
something exactly i was the
entertainment officer on my old boat hmm
i'm pretty sure the entertainment
officer doesn't exist i want all the
gear i want to be full-blown pirate yay
charlie harden
oh my gosh look at this look at it i
love it looking for treasure hello hello
come on like today for me has been just
like kind of weird yeah like you haven't
done any action yet no and i've like
constantly been on standby last night
was traumatic for me
dude i was so depressed so like went to
the captain i need help now please like
he sorted us out unbelievable seriously
i looked up the entertainment officer is
here i've never done pirate makeup in
high school i was voted most school
spirit i've always been able to throw on
a mullet or crazy outfit or become a
character it's always been a gift of
mine and i'd bring the mullets
everywhere
how's it look
pretty good
[Music]
hey captain can i come in please yes
you're chalked in you know i'm not
really much of a pirate myself either
because i didn't have a pirate costume
so i just figured i'd dress as the booty
the booty you know pirates are looking
for gold right yeah what are you looking
for
i'm more of a um brunette all-natural
kind of a man
bye bye
here they come
[Applause]
randall
hit me with some music
everybody knows the real
pirates
they come out at night
[Applause]
here we go
[Applause]
i love culver so
i think i thought you were this quiet
[Applause]
we're going to bed hey babe hey are we
getting the spot what's going on
absolutely come on
we have the towels we are in people okay
you're off now yes thanks sugar teddies
[Music]
i brought some warm towels
and some hot mullets
baby i'll try not to get a two hours oh
oh lord
are you getting involved what if i just
get in for like 10 to 15 minutes all
right you get 10 minutes
oh
yeah
oh yeah let the mullet spa party begin
[Applause]
she's like i need to go to bed and i
can't because i have crazy people
my ladies my ladies it's annoying i'm
busting my ass i want to go to bed and
you're having a great time in a mullet
with two women on my last boat i can
assure you that you would get fired i
mean come on
[Music]
you